well I was hoping to come to you today
and tell you I have such great news we
got close enough to the 500 new
financial supporters to make some really
exciting things happen we've hired
someone they're here and it was all
gonna be just so exciting and amazing
and up up and away
but sadly I I have terrible news for
people today I have actually disastrous
news genuinely I always I and Pat also
try to find silver linings in literally
everything that has ever happened on or
related to the program but I don't think
there is any silver lining here we've
been hacked and we've lost quite a few
thousands of dollars in previous show
revenue from an account with coinbase
now coinbase is the largest
cryptocurrency exchange and we use coin
base to receive cryptocurrency that is
contributed by viewers and listeners we
also use cryptocurrency to be paid for
some of the ad deals that we make with
companies that account has been hacked
and we've lost many thousands of dollars
now there's an investigation going on I
want to focus really on a solution here
I don't you know what what happened
happened coin base has totally locked up
our account which also by the way means
we can't get any of our other money out
of it for the time being until the
investigation is complete which could
take more than a month and I basically
you know we don't I don't want to give
every single detail as to how this
happened but we were having an issue
with our coin base account and I both
submitted a ticket through the coin
based website and contacted the official
verified coin based Twitter account and
that coin based Twitter account asked
publicly for our ticket number and you
know my better instincts did not kick in
and I should have realized that publicly
sending a ticket number would be a very
very bad idea and could be misused but
hey this is coin base this is the top
cryptocurrency exchange in the world if
their security protocol says it's okay
for them to publicly ask for ticket
numbers then I sent it I had a lot going
on yesterday
and that information combined with
effectively a Daxing of sorts that took
place was able to be used by a hacker
scammer to take a bunch of money from
the show that that's the bottom line
we're in touch with the FBI because this
is a theft of money right the idea that
it's cryptocurrency doesn't mean many
thousands of dollars were stolen and
that is of course a crime and my
optimistic there will be a resolution
know what I am asking you to help with
is to politely contact coinbase either
through both of their Twitter accounts
coin base and coin based support or by
emailing press at coin based comm which
I believe is more actively monitored and
say the david pakman show really got
crushed and it all goes back to that
request for a public ticket number that
really shouldn't be your protocol but we
need you to help the David Pakman show
coin base in the past has been known to
compensate individuals who are in these
situations they've also been known not
to compensate individuals who are in
these situations so I wish I had some
positive spin to put on this but it's
really really bad yeah it's been a tough
year for the show I remember last year
we were getting more views than ever
more ad revenue than ever because of the
election and write Trump's inauguration
then we got hit by the YouTube
advertiser boycott yes and things went
downhill from there recently we've been
getting into cryptocurrency and doing
these ICO reviews and we got hit by the
same thing and we got hit and also in
between those two things in the last 12
months we got completely shut down from
our Amazon affiliate link as well so
yeah it's the the the show audience has
never been bigger and yet we continue
coming across these stumbling blocks and
you know one of the worst parts about
this Pat is even though a bunch of our
crypto was stolen not all of it was but
we no longer have access to the stuff
that wasn't so even though several
thousand dollars were stolen effectively
we have access to none of it now because
even the stuff we have is all tied up
for security reasons while coinbase
conducts this investigation which again
can take a month or more yeah I found a
silver lining though okay that's we
still have our
members and our patrons yes and we still
have our health and I think that that's
an important thing not to lose sight of
people always say that you know at least
you still have your health and you've
not been physically victimized and and
all of that is true
so again less I mean number one number
one we need to see how much money we can
get back I do believe that there is some
liability here by coinbase publicly
asking for ticket numbers rather than
saying direct message us a ticket number
or do not send any ticket not write this
thing
send us your ticket number publicly is a
real problem so I do think that there is
some liability there we need to see how
much money if any we'll get back number
two have to get that account cleared and
reactivated so that we can actually
resume operations since that account is
really important to what we're doing
I'm mobilizing every resource that I can
but I am coming to you for help in
pushing this along so press at coinbase
comm tweet - at coin base and at coin
based support explain that this is a
huge thing that you are watching what
coin base is doing because I think the
the possibility that they don't handle
this well and that is publicly discussed
will maybe get them moving on this and I
promise you that if they do handle this
well and and appropriately I will update
you as well right so it's not just that
I'm out here complaining trying to trash
a company coin base is a company that
has done right by us exclusively
completely up until this time more than
a month of our money being being tied up
with no a positive resolution would be a
disaster so help us you can say this is
all related to @d Pakman or at david
pakman show on twitter or david at david
pakman.com I wish I had more to say I
don't but it's it's not been a good 24
hours that's for sure the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership